UNIFIED THE FRACTURE COMES AHEAD
OF CRITICAL VOTES AS SOON AS
FRIDAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TELLING
REPUBLICANS NOT TO BE BULLIED
INTO ALLOWING WITNESSES IN THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
WE JUST RECEIVED A STATEMENT
FROM THE LAWYER FOR JOHN BOLTON
ON HIS POSSIBLE TESTIMONY AND
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED THE NEW
NORTH AMERICAN TRADE DEAL.
AN AGREEMENT HE CALLED CUTTING
EDGE AND STATE OF THE ART AND
WAS BIPARTISAN PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
JOHN ROBERTS HAS THE STORY LIVE
FROM THE NORTH LAWN.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
IT WAS A CAMPAIGN PROMISE THE
PRESIDENT’S OPPONENTS AND EVEN
SUPPORTERS DIDN’T SEE A NEED FOR
BUT HE HAS BUILT A CASE TO
REWRITE THE TRADE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES,
CANADA AND MEXICO AND SOLD IT TO
CONGRESS.
WITH THE BACKDROP OFORKERS AND
UNION LEADERS PRESIDENT TRUMP
CELEBRATE THE BIGGEST BIPARTISAN
WIN OF HIS PRESIDENCY SIGNING
THE USMCA IN TO LAW.
>> PEOPLE SAID IT WAS TOO
COMPLICATED, COULDN’T GET DONE.
WE GOT IT DONE.
>> HE HADN’T PUT PEN TO PAPER
BEFORE NANCY PELOSI CLAIMED
CREDIT FOR IT.
>> IT WILL MAKE VAST
IMPROVEMENT.
IF IT WEREN’T WE WOULDN’T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PASS THE BILL.
>> THE CEREMONY WAS TO DRAW
CONTRAST WITH THE PROCEEDINGS ON
THE CAPITOL HILL.
AND URGING REPUBLICANS TO RESIST
INCREASETION
INCREASETION -- INCREASING
PRESSURE TO CALL WITNESSES.
SAYING REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATS
ALREADY HAD 17 WITNESSES.
WE WERE GIVEN NONE.
WITNESSES ARE UP TO THE HOUSE,
NOT UP TO THE SENATE.
DON’T LET THE DEMOCRATS PLAY
YOU.
TODAY, A REVELATION REGARDING
THE NUMBER ONE TALKED ABOUT
WITNESS, FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER JOHN BOLT JEFF.
IN A LETTER IN HIS BOOK THERE’S
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION SOME AT
THE TOP SECRET LEVEL.
MANUSCRIPT MAY NOT BE PUBLISHED
OR OTHERWISE DISCLOSED WITHOUT
THE DELETION OF THIS CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
THAT LETTER WAS SENT JANUARY 23.
THREE DAYS LATER, SIGNIFICANT
PORTIONS OF THE MANUSCRIPT WERE
LEAKED TO THE NEW YORK TIMES.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER ROBERT
O’BRIEN DOUBTS IT WAS LEAKED
FROM ANYONE UNDER HIS CHARGE.
WHILE BOLTON CLAIMS IN THE
MANUSCRIPT HE WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE UKRAINE POLICY IN THE
INTERVIEW AT THE END OF AUGUST
HE APPEARED TO SHOW NONE.
>> HE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE
SPOKEN TWICE AND THEY WERE WARM
CALLED AND THE SUCCESS OF THE
UKRAINE MAINTAINING ITS FREEDOM
AND SYSTEM OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT AND FREE-MARKET
ECONOMY FREE OF CORRUPTION AND
DEALING WITH THE PROBLEMS OF
CRIMEA ARE HIGH PRIORITIES HERE
BUT HIGH PRIORITIES FOR THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL.
>> THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF COULD
BE FUELING THE FIRE TO CALL
BOLTON.
TODAY TEARING A STRIP OFF HIM ON
TWITTER SAYING BOLTON COULDN’T
GET APPROVED FOR AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.N.
BEGGED ME FOR A NON-SENATE
APPROVED JOB AND MISTAKENLY SAYS
LIBYAN MODEL ON TV AND THEN
WRITES A NASTY AND UNTRUE BOOK,
ALL CLASSIFIED, NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE GOT A STATEMENT FROM BOLTON’S
ATTORNEY, CHUCK COOPER, WHO
INCLUDED A STATEMENT IN RESPONSE
TO THE JANUARY LETTER ABOUT
BOLTON SAYING, QUOTE, IF HE IS
CALLED TO TESTIFY IT’S CERTAIN
HE’LL BE ASKED QUESTION THAT
WILL ELICIT QUESTIONS DEALING
WITH HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH
MATTERS RELATED TO UKRAINE.
WE DON’T BELIEVE IT COULD BE
CONSIDERED CLASSIFIED AND GIVE
JEP  -- GIVEN HE COULD BE CALLED
TO TESTIFY IT’S IMPORTANT WE
HAVE THE RESULTS OF THE REVIEW
OF THAT CHAPTER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND IN THE STATEMENT
COOPER SAYS HE’S HEARD NOTHING